troisième titre à la une la grève des
comédiens des artistes ce soir l'immense
majorité des théâtres et des cafés
théâtres resteront portes closes en
lançant ce mouvement de protestation les
gens du spectacle comme on dit ils
veulent sensibiliser l'opinion et les
pouvoirs publics sur leur problèmes
d'aujourd'hui et de demain d'ailleurs
daniel cattelain ils étaient soixante
mille en 1936 vingt mille en 1968
aujourd'hui les artistes interprètes ne
sont plus que quinze mille et selon leur
syndicat
80% d'entre eux sont au chômage
endémique trois revendications
principales sont à la base de la grève
d'aujourd'hui
l'indemnisation du chômage le volume de
l'emploi les droits dérivés les
problèmes liés au chômage
le décret du 25 novembre 80 2 qui ouvre
les droits après mille heures de travail
et fixe la durée de l'indemnisation à 91
jours touche particulièrement les
professions du spectacle où le travail
intermittent est la règle l'emploi
l'accroissement des moyens financiers
des institutions culturelles n'a pas eu
selon les syndicats les effets attendus
les droits dérivés enfin à ce jour alors
que le parc des magnétoscopes est en
augmentation sensible
les artistes ne touchent encore aucun
droit sur la vente ou la location des
cassettes
alors pour parler de toutes ces
revendications nous avons invité antenne
de midi de comédien henri virlojeux
henri virlojeux c'est le comédien connu
on voit beaucoup d'ailleurs à la
télévision donc les français vous
connaissent bien vous avez du travail
et puis une autre artiste une autre
comédienne que les français ne
connaissent pas ce truc son nom elle
s'appelle catherine laborde et l'a
pourtant fait quelques dramatique en
télévision elle avait notamment
travaillé avec michel subi hélas pour la
dramatique meurtre sur la personne de la
mer il est obligé de passer par les
publicités pour pouvoir survivre
alors on va évoquer les deux aspects de
cette grève le premier c'est celui qui
porte sur demain henri virlojeux car des
artistes comme vous qui ont du travail
ne sont pas tellement préoccupés par les
problèmes de la cie
dick mais surtout par la question des
droits dérivés avec maintenant l'arrivée
sur le marché les magnétoscopes
bien sûr notre pause d'aujourd'hui que
j'appelle une pause de 24 heures je
n'envoie pas des salles maugrey ve c'est
une pause de réflexion il me semble
qu'elle n'a jamais été aussi calme aussi
tranquille et aussi résolu c'est la
première fois qu'on trouve une une
adhésion une coopération presque totale
chez tous les gens concernés par cet
arrêt du travail le problème des droits
de suite est un problème très important
pour nous car le public le sait ou ne le
sais pas mais je tiens à le lui faire
savoir c'est que notre participation
artistique à une émission doit un
travail théâtral est une participation
réellement artistique
ce n'est pas qu'une participation
d'interprètes très souvent actuellement
j'ai la chance de travailler sur un
texte que je n'ai pas écrit qui a été
écrit par d'autres personnes mais on me
demande mon avis et ma coopération je
participe donc artistiquement à ce
travail je ne signe pas mais j'apporte
quelque chose de moi de ma conscience de
mon coeur de mon esprit et je pense que
si dans dix ans je vois cette émission
passer à la télévision je me trouverais
très coupable de n'avoir rien obtenu sur
ma participation
alors vous avez des termes qui somme qui
peut rendre sa des revendications vous
parlez de pause et non pas de grève et
pourtant tout le monde dit on voit le
spectre de la grève des acteurs
américains
oui bien sûr mais je sens que il est bon
nous nous avons eu des expériences de
grève et nos grèves étaient impopulaires
parce qu'elle était mal comprise et
surtout mal expliqué et je pense que ce
qui est important aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça je dis pause parce que ce n'est pas
un véritable arrêt de travail
c'est une réflexion en arrêtant de
travail c'est pourquoi je n'en veux pas
à ce qu'ils continuent à travailler car
ils font peut-être ce soir une annonce
et s'ils ne font pas l'annoncent
eh bien nous nous chargerons de leur
expliquer pourquoi il serait dû
peut-être s'arrêter
c'est leur intérêt bien alors il ya une
solidarité entre les riches et les
pauvres chez les comédiens la preuve en
est avec
avec henri virlojeux et catherine
laborde vous catherine vous faites
plutôt grève pour la question des miller
qui est imposée maintenant avec la
nouvelle loi novembre 80 deux dames
nisation du chômage enfin pas trop
séparés parce que le principal problème
c'est l'emploi
nous on a choisi un métier on a de la
chance de pouvoir choisir un métier
donc on n'est pas heureux quand on
travaille pas et on est très content
quand on travaille à la première chose
c'est l'emploi alors maintenant il ya de
moins en moins de travail et pas
seulement dans les centres culturels
comme ça a été dit dans le reportage mot
c'est la télé est de moins en moins de
travail à la télé il m'a peut-être dans
les pubs il y en a plus dans la
dramatique l'un des feuilletons ou en
tout cas de moins en moins et encore
pour cette année alors nous ce qu'on
veut c'est travailler mais quand on
travaille pas il faut qu'on nous aide à
continuer a duré à tenir jusqu'au
prochain travail puisqu'on des
intermittents vous par exemple ou taille
et combien d'heures dans la millième de
jours dans le moule oui bon je travaille
je sais pas moi c'est quand j'ai de la
chance 50 jours par an
les résultats je suis pas en vacances
sur le chômage alors est-ce que l'on
peut vivre de cette manière est ce qu'on
peut assumer sa condition de comédiens
de manière décente de manière décente si
on si on a le droit de toucher des
assedic parce que c'est un droit c'est
comme le droit de travailler si on n'a
que le droit de travailler pas devra
toucher les assedic ont peu plus or
maintenant
avant il fallait 60 cacher on était
indemnisé pendant 365 jours et bien avec
maintenant le même nombre de cachets on
sera indemnisée trois mois j'ai qui peut
en trois mois faire 60 caché en tout cas
peu d'acteurs parce que même si vous
avez un rôle important la télé ce qui
m'arrive pas très souvent
mais si vous avez un rôle important la
télé c'est 20 à cacher donc faudrait
avoir trois rôles principaux à la télé
en une année rien n'a pas beaucoup
pensable je vous allez dire que je me
fais l'avocat du diable simplement en
elle un sentiment avec cette pause comme
le dit monsieur virlojeux quand on
défend aussi bien les bons comédiens que
les mauvais comédien mais c'est quoi un
vent mauvais comédien ah bon combien
c'est peut-être celui que que l'on
appelle souvent pour travailler parce
qu'il a du talent ouais ça peut être ça
et puis c'est bien mais on peut être
aussi un bon comédien s'est pas tout à
fait les mêmes qualités qui font qu'on
travaille qu'on travaille pas il ya les
qualités sur un plateau une fois qu'on
est engagée qu'on a le rôle
et puis a les qualités aussi pour
trouver du travail
aie aie aussi faut il faut pas se mettre
ça dans la tête qu'on travaille pas
parce qu'on est mauvais on travaille pas
parce qu'il ya pas de travail non plus
y'a pas trop d'acteurs 1
la france est un des pays où il ya le
moins d'acteurs par rapport à la
population par rapport aux pays d'europe
y'a pas trop d'acteurs il n'y a pas
assez de travail et c'est aussi
important que du travail pour les
acteurs que du travail dans l'industrie
c'est aussi important pour le pays la
culture merci catherine laborde j'espère
que vous aurez été entendu par l'opinion
publique et par les pouvoirs publics
puisque c'est le sens de votre démarche
avec henri virlojeux et les autres
jambes du spectacle
non